see ya yeah yeah yeah fea the area when
i first was introduced to it i was told
luis fear but then the guy on stage
seemed to be just saying fee so I'm from
the north of England and fear is how you
would say fear because we don't
pronounce the consonants properly or
vowels so I mean oh but overall this
seemed like a replacement for yarny this
was another super cute emotional fun
indie game that i really appreciated
that like the little guy was super cute
like little was odd guy well you know
he's communicating with other animals
and that seems to play a big part in the
game which is adorable everyone loves
that curious how they will all play out
like really what the objective is in the
end but I found most interesting is this
was tied to the initiative to you know
support creatives give them a chance
they wouldnt get otherwise and also let
the profits go back to them yes i think
is great so it's like the square enix
collective kind of thing yeah but but it
seems it seems like they work in the
model a little bit differently when i
first saw fay fee they showed off
concept offers and i thought this looks
a lot like limbo I mean this looks
exactly like limbo meet sorry but
looking at the actual game emotion looks
kind of like tear away I felt and it
uses sound in a very what seems like a
unique way we didn't get to play at
hands on but in anything that uses music
and sound to create these kind of
emotional escapes like that i always
think that's really exciting is very
unique i mean you can look at it now it
has a really kind of a very like a fox
yeah it's like little fennec fox thing
kind of Pokemon is this is it this is
the bit where I thought it looked a lot
like tear away just in the way that the
character moves very angular kind of
world but I makes I'm definitely excited
to see what I'm also excited to see now
that EA putting more money behind these
short these you know smaller studios
giving chances two games that maybe
wouldn't get picked up by anywhere else
so I'm excited to see that but in terms
of triple A's I mean we got like the
triple a quake champions the Big Daddy
is back did anyone see that coming we
kind of their people at least like
pretending like the new is coming yeah
oh yeah I knew about it
I heard of quakecon yeah there was like
all those resumes like earlier this year
I guess there was like a mass higher at
it or they posted something that sort of
inferred that they were working on quake
um I mean it's been a long time coming i
think after doom this was like the
perfect time for them to sort of re
announced that they're rebooting some
stuff enough and i love to the success
of Wolfenstein as well i'm the new the
new order and the old blood yep kind of
make that it made sense to go back to
those old it prophecies and they're
certainly chasing the hero shooter genre
without really calling it as such which
is maybe a smart move I don't know that
that's what quake fans want but maybe
that won't matter in the long run if it
just plays the same way yeah I hope it's
gonna be that they said they'll be an
unlocked frame rate on pc i think they
say up to 120 hertz which is blindingly
fast damn well but I mean obviously no
gameplay just a the old CGI trailer
we're going to hear more about it at
quakecon another Bethesda reveal then
pray it's not pray to its prey again
it's arcane's reimagining what do we
think of the reveal yeah that was such a
cool trailer like it was very moody and
like I love playing with time and and
kind of what your expectations are
because even with in that trailer I'm
like I'm not sure what's going on and
you're learning a little bit more about
this story in this world and it made me
want to learn and no more yeah yeah I
don't know why I decided to call it pray
I don't know that that brand really
draws a lot of attention I think it is a
cool name though it ain't sure yeah but
it does have this attachment yeah but
aside from that the trailer was really
interesting it showed some stuff that
the character himself seems to be the
focal point it's not mechanics it's not
something else it's a guy who's really
struggling through something he's not
really sure what's going on and so that
kind of makes me interested because well
i'm curious now i want to know what's
going on so I'd be great to go on that
journey with him but rather than just
taking a name for a game that doesn't
necessarily fit exactly i think they
could have taken another beloved
franchise they could have call the
Battletoads know that they could have
called Battletoads I'm interested in
seeing how it is out because I mean
basically it's um it's alien isolation
you wake up on a
on a craft you're by yourself there
seems to be some sort of technip ulation
happening with this character where he's
both being manipulated but also uh sort
of he's out of sorts so you don't know
if he's actually be manipulated or it's
just in his head or if he's doing it to
himself he greets himself in the mirror
here yeah that wasn't that was one of
those those twilight zone type yes black
mirror I say yeah it would have reminded
me of that surreal kind of weirdness
yeah but Microsoft stayed we had I mean
this was probably no surprise they
needed a fort sir this year thoughts
arising three go to Australia who saw
that coming not major card out of town I
am kind of disappointed that there
wasn't like a giant car supercar on
stage they usually do but you know photo
horizon I think it's a fun game um I
certainly prefer it to regular ford
sucks i'm not i'm not a racing same
person but the more arcadey feel the
music i really like what is it about
this that draws you in considering that
you like the last one to be honest when
I spring the last one because last one
um was it the music festival the one
before when it's just the way that the
music blends in really well I mean
obviously the story my story bit or a
bit me with the little videos of people
playing but it's it's more fun its
arcade and the way that the the drivatar
as all as our word is works it's really
fun to be able to see your friends
playing alongside you and beating them
and it's like the classic it's the
ghosts that you're like playing with
it's easy to play with friends looks
like the crew already yeah go there yeah
I don't think the cruise around anymore
but i know i mean i just also the way
that the the cars handle is very
satisfying I'm not by any means a big
racing fan at all but Forza horizon i
always think is a game that i can play
and I'm not intimidated by which i am by
regular folks I'm really waiting for the
DLC since it's in Australia either I get
to have a kangaroo is my driver where I
get to ride a kangaroo because I would
totally do that that's an amazing idea
actually she's right okay okay good um
but we also saw gwent yeah so I mean do
you think CD Projekt RED realized how
popular but card game would be
like not when they first made it no but
after looking at hearthstone and the
ridiculous success of something like
that it I think it was a foregone
conclusion that that was going to come
they weren't inspired by triple triad
where's that card game i want that card
game but no I mean it has a story mode
and stuff you think that's gonna work
well I don't know like I mean where's
your fans are gonna play it I don't know
that anyone who's not into the witcher
will go for it is it such a niche thing
yeah my favorite part apart stone it was
the single player story missions and
that could be really interesting in
gwent both getting you used to playing
it and understanding the mechanics while
not forcing you to play against other
people so does the idea of two lanes no
that's that's a different game sorry I'm
confusing it means remotes no i was i
was thinking of the Elder Scrolls
legends game yes got to yes students um
anyway I tried playing Gwen because you
can you cannot play it in the game when
I was playing Witcher 3 I did kind of
forgo it and I always had people on
Twitter go like oh my god this Gwen look
I'm didn't matter yeah exactly like get
good at Gwen but now um Xbox also
revealed state of decay to what are we
expecting that well I mean so we knew
that um undead labs the developer was
working on a successor they were working
on some kind of MMO type thing that was
codenamed i think was class for they've
been talking about that since state of
decay blew up xbox live and became like
the best downloadable best-selling
downloadable game of all time on xbox
live so we knew something else was
coming from them I'm a little surprised
that I mean I am surprised and also not
surprised that they called it state of
decay to obviously state of decay sold
well so maybe labeling it as such will
allow people to like find it better and
give it a little bit more press but um I
really liked state of decay and it
worked really well and I'm totally
excited to like this one did any of you
guys playgro home yes yeah I say I
didn't but I was I like the Qt platform
us also when grow up was an ounce yeah
well it leaked I mean in the great
leaking it was when the revealed games
what do you think well so grow home had
sort of a very awkward control scheme
which was part of the charm of it and I
guess I'm really curious how that game
is going to
evolved because grow home on its own i
think stands fairly well like i don't
think it needs a sequel so it grow up
has something different then i'll be
really excited if it's just more the
same i don't know that that's enough to
make me want to go back in it's a game
that's fun but it's not a game that's
that's got a whole lot of depth to it
because it was like a short relatively
short game but i think this one's going
to be a full-priced game judging by the
amazon wow yeah so they must have um for
a new mechanic because grow hombre did
that so well and like I I'd loved
playing it I loved enjoying that
experience and it was the right length
because it also could get very tiring
yeah I would have wanted to see
something different when they're calling
it a different name like I would have
imagined like oh we're gonna burrow into
the ground or something different but
yeah you know even sorry on the siebel
in our use of pre show we were saying
it's been a while since we've seen
trials and then bam out they came when I
revealed in Evans from fog right blood
dragon tracksuits oh wow amazing those
outfits work a plus I'd like to think
that they went shopping for those
together yo you know that it oh ya
ordene Bob both of them yes so the
trials of the Blood Dragon is it enough
to bring us back to trials yeah I love
trials anyway so new courses and a new
aesthetic I'm totally sold yep but it
seems like her it's not just bikes
anymore its kind of these buggy tank
things you can also get out so you can
go by foot and you have to shoot things
oh it looks so good it's like someone
threw up the 80s on two trials it's so
good sweet preorder bonus yeah right you
guys I would love if they exited create
those hoping for dragon action figures
you uh a new purse off thought the big
unannounced project was I did not see
this coming steep I don't think anybody
saw it coming because it's in my butt is
like an MMO extreme sports game like
yeah it's but it's cool like I think
it's a weird idea when somebody said it
to me I was like oh that's dumb but then
you watch people play it and it's kind
of funny and it seems like it would easy
to jump into and I'm actually more
excited hearing especially our other
energies got to try it out yeah they
made it sound like a whole lot of fun
they sort of you know talked about
emergent co-op stuff similar to
who was example my cues I don't know but
yeah it does have that fun yeah um I
think you've heard the GTA online oh oh
yeah just kind of like the crazy Wow a
lot people yeah yeah um watching people
bite it and die because they would not
survive this also in some kind of like
photo mode to sort of manipulate the
bodies as they're crumbling to the
ground oh my god yeah I don't know it
looks really good I don't know i mean
i'm not a big extreme sports fan but i
do like messing around and multiplayer
with my friends I know this looks like
the sort of thing where it's going to be
the physics and these sort of other you
know the unrealistic things that occur
yeah so I don't think you really need to
be a sports fan cuz I don't really
follow extreme sports but this looks
really fun yeah I do this every weekend
yeah I wanted what you got up to smell a
cool like you that's why old might let I
don't stand out my legs are broken yeah
that's fine he don't take your shoes off
either yeah they're grafted in um a
little brief chat about the VR that sony
revealed Batman V our Alfred yelling the
VR around is the best joke that I ever
made um do we I mean would you prefer a
no just another arkham game or is this a
nice twist on love games the franchise
I'd be into it if it was like it was
Batman V are but you weren't playing as
Batman like you were playing as Alfred
mmm or someone else having to watch
Bruce Wayne God's gonna be late for
dinner and right I feel like making you
Batman is the obvious choice and I feel
like there are now like going to be so
many VR experiences where your action
hero flipping around doing whatever like
we're getting doom and fall out and like
we're not getting doom that was an
experience as getting a doom experience
yeah and fall out um so I would totally
play like an Alfred simulator in VR
resident evil 7 is the only be our thing
that was shown at the show that matters
at all mmm that's true guys thank you so
much for joining me of course if you
want or more news impressions develop
interviews from this year's it III make
sure you keep your eyes peeled to
gamespot
you